- Gary Vaynerchuk here, reporting live
from the Orlando Airport.
(energetic bass music)
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
(energetic bass music)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(snappy R&B music)
- [Lead Speaker] Or a blogger,
or a late-night show host or--
- [Gary] Morning.
(solitary cheer)
What I'm scared about is you're all
playing a game for 2016 that is in
your best of interest, as you should,
cause you're a human being.
The problem is, if you're
not paying attention,
the game that we're all gonna be playing
in 2026, they're gonna judge you poorly.
Please go look back at the
last 3 industrial revolutions.
People that got hurt the most look exactly
like the people in this room.
Which were they were
making behavior for the
prior game, they were
training for basketball
and the world made them play hockey.
(Symphony No. 5)
- [Presentation] One
simple swap of a letter
is changing the name from IHOP to IHOB
which really rolls off the tongue.
It's the name change that is
driving the internet crazy.
Change it back! No one is--
(applause)
- There were some scary
moments, but it was fun.
(crowd laughs)
- [Lead Speaker] How did you know?
You mentioned that you
were able to look out--
- [Lead Speaker] Onwards to
the CEO of GaryVee Media,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
(thumping bass music)
- [Gary] Thank you, my
friend. Good to see you.
(thumping bass music)
Good morning.
One thing I love to do is
actually encourage Q&A.
I heard, cause I haven't been here
the last couple of days,
that no human has come to the mike
in the entire three days so as much as
I love technology and apps
and (bleep) like that,
I'd love somebody to come up at some point
if they have a question when we transition
in about 20 minutes.
I would say this one thing.
If you actually believe
something in a meeting,
and it might be against the grain,
saying it in a respectful way matters
because in three years
when it becomes true,
the other seven people in that room
will remember that and that may lead
to the growth in your career that
you're looking for.
People think they grow in their career
by staying within the framework
of their organization.
They're actually quietly, subconsciously
ruining their career if they don't agree
with the point of view and I know for fact
because the best part of
CAN for me, hands down,
is two, 3 o'clock in the morning
when people have so much Rose in them
they start talking truth.
(crowd laughing)
I know for fact that
there's a lot of people
that have strategies or executions
they don't personally believe in.
It's just the framework of where
the margin is in their company
or what they have to be held accountable
to a bonus, and that's a
tough life in some way.
This is only just work.
There's much bigger things going on.
I will say, being on the record in a room
respectfully of what you
actually believe brave
is a very, very good idea.
And honestly, back to brave,
there's so much content.
There's so much going on in the world.
What I think this room
believes and defines as brave
is actually the only
prayer to breakthrough
consumer tension; to make something happen
in your business.
Thank you!
(applause)
You're the best.
(inspiring piano music)
- You're an awesome guest.
Thank you, guys!
(applause)
(inspiring piano music)
- Outside of this, what are you doing?
- In life?
- Yeah.
- I think we need to
have more conversations
around self-awareness and happiness.
- Agreed. So, why is that not happening?
- People are insecure.
- Okay. But you don't
think people obviously,
I mean to your point, they're
thinking about these things.
They have the Rose at 3 a.m. and like,
Oh, there's people here--
- Oh, you mean the iPods.
- No, not even marketing wise but
like God and reason and purpose.
- Yeah. It's heavy shit for humans.
- It's the most important, right?
- The good news is you can
control what you can control.
- Right. No, of course.
- That's it.
- So I can speak it and create it myself.
- That's what I love. I do what I do.
I put out content about my belief in it.
Some people connect with
it and you move forward.
- Yeah.
- You can't boil the ocean, you know?
One step at a time.
- Yeah. It's just like
shocking that more people aren't like
what the fuck are we doing?
- Just focus on your
shit, and do, and then
you'll inspire others to do.
- Cool. Alright, man.
- Take care man.
- Good meeting you.
- The point is we all here have
a obligation to try to make something
happen for our businesses, and I say
with that dollar, Laurie,
what can you do best?
And to me, we cloud it with
lines and different points.
To me, it's just everyday.
LinkedIn.
Right now my life is
LinkedIn, organic content
cause the organic reaches through the roof
like Facebook seven years ago
and I'm gonna squeeze the fuck out of it
and as soon as it goes
away we're like fuck that.
I've built my whole
life on Google Adwords.
I spend nothing on Google Adwords now.
Chris, when I tell you that
in the next half-decade
it's gonna be 500 times worse,
it is the singular
reason I think a company
that is as great as yours could actually
look like Sirius and
I really believe that.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- If you do not build
up your DPC capabilities
without causing conflict in your channels,
you'll go out of business.
- And that's the hard part right there--
- (bleep)
- conflicts, right?
- Dude. This is real.
I'm telling you there is a
naivete in this collective
of what's about to
happen and the only thing
that is actually ownable and controllable
is contemporary marketing to build brand
so you can trade on that only currency,
because if you are not
selling direct to consumer
you are now 100% vulnerable.
- I decided to start my year this year
starting my day with your
podcast in the morning.
- Thank you.
- And you guys and your whole team are
so fucking killing it on the content side.
My whole team jokes cause
everyday I'm quoting Gary Vee.
I've been saying 100%
in every conversation.
- 100%.
100%.
100%
- Anyway. I just wanted
to thank you for that
cause I do feel like
it's impacted my energy
and I'm just so passionate
about all of it.
Someone just yesterday was
like why do you love Gary Vee?
I know you push pressure a lot, but for me
The Thank You Economy changed my career.
Literally. In terms of
building confidence and
knowing that you'd get it.
- I push happiness and self-awareness
much more than crushing it.
It's just crushing it
gets all the attention--
- Yeah.
- Cause it's a lightening bolt of oh see?
Overwork. People are looking for things.
If you listen, it's very clear.
- What thought box do you go from?
How do you get into that frame of mind
where you are like--
- It's my permanent frame on mind.
It's having a really
awesome mother, having
a lot of adversity as a kid.
Circumstances. I take no pride.
It comes naturally.
Some people can sing.
Things are just very clear.
Human behavior is very clear to me.
Growing up as a retailer
is a big advantage.
Everyday Courtney and
Laurie, they come in.
Everyday was like I have
this party for wine.
All I ever knew was this
person needs something.
They're in my neighborhood.
I can milk her for a wine that
I'm making more money on,
but based on what she
said if I ever want her
to come back, I better
give her the right thing.
Being a retailer in a
family business in our
neighborhood is an
incredible framework for
being consumer centric.
In hindsight, and it's
probably in the last two years,
I'm like, wait a minute.
Maybe this is why.
I'll end up just being
kind. I'm a kind guy.
I like beauty in others.
Plus, if you're running a marathon
you do long-term behavior.
If you're running a sprint,
you do short-term behavior,
so I think that is also
an advantage for us.
Gary Vaynerchuk here reporting live from
the Orlando Airport where once again
he hit the stage and he
did what he had to do
which is be historically correct
and speak his truth, and anybody
who speaks their truth
with the hope of being
historically correct
tend to win the marathon,
and life is a marathon
unless you get hit by a bus.
(inspiring piano music)